vous avez dit que des actions telles que celles-ci suggèrent
autrement suggèrent ce qui signifie qu'ils
suggèrent qu'ils ne sont pas intéressés par les pourparlers
et qu'ils vont aller de l'avant avec une
sorte d'offre de quelle action
parlez-vous
une des actions que je viens de signaler euh
le  fait que la russie continue de s'engager
euh dans la désinformation euh il a fait une
allégation qu'ils pourraient faire cela l'ont-
ils réellement fait euh ce que nous savons
mat est ce que nous ce que je viens de dire
qu'ils se sont engagés dans cette activité
dans cette activité de planification
mais laissez  laissez-moi parce que
ce n'est évidemment pas la
première fois que nous rendons euh
ces rapports publics, vous vous souviendrez
qu'il y a quelques semaines à peine, désolé de
rendre public quel rapport
si vous me laissez terminer, je vous dirai
quel rapport nous  rendu public euh nous vous avons dit
il y a quelques semaines que nous avons des
informations indiquant que la russie a également
déjà prépositionné un groupe d'
agents pour mener une
opération sous fausse bannière dans l'est de l'ukraine afin que la carte
à votre question soit un ac  tion que la
russie a déjà pris c'est une action
que vous dites qu'ils ont prise mais
vous n'avez montré aucune preuve pour confirmer
cela et je vais passer à la
question suivante ici qui est quelle est la
preuve qu'ils je veux dire c'est  comme les
acteurs de crise, c'est vraiment comme le
territoire d'Alex Jones dans lequel vous entrez maintenant,
euh, quelles preuves avez-vous pour soutenir
l'idée qu'il y a un
film de propagande en cours de réalisation
matt cela est dérivé euh d'informations
connues du gouvernement américain  informations de
renseignement que nous avons déclassifiées je
pense bien eh bien où sont-elles où sont
ces informations ce sont des
informations de renseignement que nous avons déclassifiées
bien où sont-elles où sont les
informations déclassifiées je viens de les
livrer
non vous avez fait une série d'allégations
voudriez-vous  nous d'imprimer
le topper parce que vous verrez une
transcription de ce briefing que vous pouvez
imprimer vous-même ce n'est pas une preuve
que vous le dites ce n'est pas une preuve que
je suis  Pardon